so you've done I just found out is it 19
[Applause]
since I was 7 so I've been doing this a
long time and I've worked with a lot of
different people a lot of great people
that they very much what the you know
the values that their their movies
emulate they they are like that as a
company and as people and I'm so
thankful to work alongside them they
become friends so Christmas and Rome
right that's that it's your eighth
holiday Hallmark film right my eighth
and now down to Christmas movie yeah
amazing yeah did you love it is this a
good one it'll catch a fun one you know
we try to make each one different and
special and while the messages are all
very similar this one was particularly
fun because I get to go to Rome and my
character lives there and she's a tour
guide and it's her passion to show
people this beautiful city in a way that
they've never seen it before
so she encounters Sam Paige plays Oliver
a wonderful actor and he's there on a
business trip and doesn't really plan on
seeing the city so it's her mission to
show him what Rome is really about
what's at the heart of it oh I love it
she heard about it that's do you love
Christmas is that why you're in eight
films I love Christmas I love decorating
for Christmas early although like total
confession because I've been busy making
these movies I had him I got to up my
game again I couldn't have 75% of our
presents already have you really so when
I do I've got Christmas music going
wrapping in my dining room like a crazy
person
and I love your Christmas music oh thank
you thank you I love
[Applause]
so what's Christmas like at the mcgraw
house should we confess yes we we when
it comes that time of year if you see we
don't like Christmas almost man no
listen Oh tell me if I'm lying we we
record every Hallmark Christmas movie
every year and watch every one of them
[Applause]
still got like 30 of them recorded on
our DVR yes and then we just like binge
watching we see everyone I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this